it's great you know four gigs he's still  to be playing at the highest level four  years old at a club that you know he's  from Manchester so the fact that he's  been able to continue his career at one  club for the amount of time is really  incredible it's something that his  family would be very proud of and manche  night fans would be unbelievably proud  what do you put it down to is it in the  person or is this the lifestyle that you  know in the person it's in the lifestyle  it's the way you look after yourself the  way you train you know it's a number of  elements but you know there's not many  players that can say that they've played  to a 40th top level